dans cette pharmacie le stock de gel
hydro alcoolique est épuisée depuis
presque un mois
alors lorsque l' oms a autorisé les
officines à fabriquer elle-même leurs
produits la pharmacienne a aussitôt
réagi en labo on suit précisément la
formule officielle est un hall à 95%
peroxyde d'hydrogène glycérine et eau
distillée
le résultat n'est alors pas un gel mais
une solution liquide c'est moins
pratique parce que c'est moins c'est
clair
on a fait le test et en fin de compte
c'est ça ne colle pas
ça ça reste pas sur les mains après pour
on n'a pas eu les flacons adéquate c'est
à dire on n'a pas eu de flacons
distributeurs bon après ça dérange pas
ici les flacons seront en vente dans
quelques jours à prix coûtant mais
surtout pas en libre service
on pense eu quantité
au jour d'aujourd'hui que près de 1300
flacon de 30 mn une fois qu'ils seront
épuisés selon s'ils y arrivent âge à
nouveau de matières premières ont
pourront continuer la production 6-1-1
plus on sera comme tout le monde
en pénurie car une rupture de stock peut
en cacher une autre
les deux grossistes de martinique sont
déjà en pénurie de certains composants
comme la glycérine achète cher c'est
autres officines s'est bien essayé à la
réalisation de quelques flacons mais
elle n'ira pas plus loin son labo n'est
pas équipé d'extracteurs d'air le
préparateur iris querelles intoxication
à l'alcool nous c'était pas destinés à
la vente
on a vraiment fait un essai pour voir ce
que ça allait donner
mais c'est compliqué en termes de normes
même si vous avez l'autorisation
voilà c'est ça c'est une autorisation
qui n'en a pour l'instant
alors ici on restera tributaire des
fournisseurs de gel de l'hexagone la
semaine prochaine peut-être on a
commandé chez notre fournisseur habituel
mais déjà en janvier c'était compliqué
de
en avoir donc maintenant je vous raconte
pas c'est même à mon avis ce sera ce
sera encore plus difficile alors
fabrication locale ou pas les produits
hydro-alcooliques seront toujours un peu
difficile à trouver
heureusement tout le monde ne cède pas à
la panique ne cherchez pas en avoir
bon dieu patois inquiet je suis dans la
domaine médical donc j'en utilise déjà
les gens nés oui mais pas plus que
d'habitude
heureusement j'ai fait mon stack avant
mais oui c'est un produit que
j'utilisais c'est quotidiennement
vacances j'ai pas à disponibilité savon
et diallo simplement l'eau et le savon
réputé en effet plus efficace lorsqu'on
n'y a accès ils sont aussi moins
agressif que l'alcool sur la peau
surtout pour les petits les pharmaciens
en déconseille lusage répétés sur les
enfants